Matt and I have used Wolfram
technologies and three hecka phones now
and we've won prizes in all three of
them
we have turned users into designers
through algorithms and we've been able
to do it in the really short time crunch
that hackathons allow using the stuff
that already exists and Wolfram
it would have been impossible without it
my name is Olivia Walsh and I'm a
graduate student in mathematics at the
University of Michigan
I'm Matt Jacobson I'm also a graduate
student in math at the University of
Michigan I'm kind of almost new to the
programming world I started doing it
with tacca thumbs when Olivia just told
me to come along and that was just back
in January and that was sort of the
first time that I really did any
programming sort of hardcore programming
and it was in the Wolfram language it
was so easy to pick up and learn quickly
you know by the end of the 36 hours at
the hackathon we were just writing code
and we created this amazing product that
one it was this epic transformation to
you it was it was really cool just
seeing how that after one hackathon like
knew how to program in the Wolfram
language he picked it up so quickly and
he and then that was his gateway
language chosen then he went into C C++
everything but really I have Wolfram to
thank for that of just making it so easy
to get in there and not be scared of
programming so at the first hackathon we
went to which was M hacks 5 at the
University of Michigan what we created
was what we call sketch anything so the
idea is that you can take any image and
we will automatically generate drawing
guides that teach you how to draw it so
again it's building on this theme of
turning users into designers you don't
have to buy some book that's already
predetermined of what you're going to
draw you can just pick the thing that
you're interested in and our algorithm
takes care of that for you it's a it's
based on a blog post from Wolfram's
Michael trot I think we are
I don't know just sit around at the
table being like that guy is great yeah
I was reading through the block feels
like this is so because he has this blog
post we talked about how they make the
person curves and the Pikachu curves
which are really just these long Fourier
series expansions of the lines they
found in the image and that's how we got
into this idea okay what if we actually
do this foot worse what if we use a very
short Fourier approximation of these
lines and it comes out to be very simple
shapes like circles and swoops and it's
this beautiful case where math solves a
problem and we didn't even have the
problem in mind at first we're like no
this this looks like a drawing guide and
and it's the solution that matches so
nicely so we won M hacks got a ton of
swag as a result and won a trip to
Taiwan as a part of that swag for
another hackathon we did called hack NTU
and after after M hacks I think there
was no way we weren't going to use how
can do you